Narrator: These are the Sharks.
They have achieved incredible
success as entrepreneurs
and investors
in multiple sectors.
They all came from
humble beginnings
and are all self‐made.
The Sharks know what it takes
to build business empires
from nothing into billions.
Now they are investing
in entrepreneurs' dreams.
We're building this thing
to be an empire.
What you don't have
is focus.
There's no way I'm gonna do
an attitude shift.
Are you kidding?
Who wants
to be a part of it?
I don't know how I get around
that number.
You blew it!
Narrator: This is the art
of doing business.
I'm not talking to the owner,
I'm talking to the hired help!
Some people call me
the Doll‐atollah.
NARRATOR:
This is "Shark Tank."
This episode's gonna go viral.
No way!
You need to drop a mic
right about now.
♪♪
Narrator:
First into the tank
is a couple with an innovation
in pet products.
[ Laughter ]
Hi, Sharks. Let me introduce
ourselves. I'm Tara.
And I'm Jason.
We're the founders
of PDX Pet Design.
And today, we're asking for
$300,000 for 15% of our company.
Now Jason and I are
of the generation
that grew up online
with computers,
so, naturally,
we met online.
We eventually got married,
and you know what happens next.
We adopted more cats!
[ Greiner and Herjavec chuckle ]
The problem with cat toys
today ‐‐ It's this.
They're cute, they're colorful,
but when you take them home,
your cats play with them
for about five minutes.
These guys are basically
throwaway.
Imagine instead
you could walk into a pet shop,
and there'd be
an entire aisle dedicated
to the wellness
of your cat.
With products that enhance
your kitty's lifestyle
and really help you improve
your relationship with your cat.
Well that's what we are doing
at PDX Pet Design.
For our first product,
we created SHRU ‐‐
the intelligent
cat companion.
As you can see
in the video,
SHRU entertains your cat
while you're out for the day.
Now we designed SHRU to mimic
a small animal's motion.
So it ignites the hunting
instinct of your little tiger.
It's basically going to be
your cat's new BFF.
For our next product,
we looked at the fact
that cats groom each other
as a form of social bonding.
There's also evidence
that suggests
that your cat thinks
you're a big cat, not a human.
So, why should you
be left out
of their intimate
bonding ritual?
Well, with LICKI Brush you don't
have to be left out anymore.
LICKI Brush is
the tongue shaped brush
you can use to finally lick
your cat ‐‐
just like a mama cat
licks her young.
No, you're not gonna stick that
in your mouth are you?
Yeah.
[ All groaning ]
Oh, that ‐‐
No way!
Cuban: Kevin! Kevin,
demonstrate how it's done!
Oh, my goodness!
You're joking!
Oh, they're freaks!
Tara: Oh, I'm not joking.
You're joking!
No. So, who wants
to join us
on the quest to improve
kitty lives around the world?
There is not ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
Now ‐‐
Now, Sharks ‐‐
Somebody hands you ‐‐ You need
to drop a mic right about now.
That is
horrible!
Tara: We're gonna give
each of you guys a cat
and a LICKI Brush and a SHRU
so you can test it out.
Oh, no, you're not!
Oh, yes, we are.
I want a cat.
What's the name
of the cat?
Chestnut.
Chestnut is now
psychologically disturbed.
Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
Robert,
if you could take a cat.
Jason,
what happened, man?
[ Laughs ]
What happened
to you, man?
This has been
a viral hit.
Cuban:
I bet it has.
I'll try it
with the real cat.
Hi, baby.
So, you just put it
in your mouth,
and you want to lick her
with the grain, right?
You don't want to go
against the grain,
as any pet owner knows.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God!
Yeah, so, you just hold her nice
and tight ‐‐ There you go!
Nicely done.
Oh, my God.
I ‐‐
I hate myself
so much right now.
Jason: People use it,
and they say this is
a wonderful bonding experience
with their animal.
[ Laughs ]
Greiner: But, like,
what's the difference
if you were to put this
in your mouth and lick the cat,
or if you were just to, like,
brush the cat?
Yeah, I'm just brushing her,
and she likes that.
Well, then
it's just a brush.
[ Laughs ]
Okay, guys,
I want to take it seriously
because you asked
for $300,000
before I saw you
lick a cat with this.
Well, we don't know
what their sales are.
How many did you sell?
To date we have sold
about $250,000 worth of SHRU
and about $52,000 worth
of LICKI Brush.
We have five other designs
in the pipeline right now,
and we think they're gonna be
equally viral.
We know how to talk to people
on the Internet about cats.
What did you guys do
before lickity split?
Well, I'm uh,
an electrical engineer by trade,
which makes
perfect sense.
Jason's created SHRU
and LICKI Brush himself.
We have not outsourced
any of the contracting,
the engineering ‐‐
We do everything.
Good for you.
And I work on the
business‐management side of it.
I actually went to
the University of Waterloo,
Mr. Wonderful.
You did?
Yeah, and then I went on to
explore a PhD in neuroscience.
Are you a Canadian?
I sure am.
No kidding.
Greiner: She's targeting you.
She thinks you might be
a cat lover.
I'm gonna make sure they
throw you out of the country.
[ Laughter ]
Herjavec: Did we ever ask you
how much it sells for?
No, you haven't.
Okay.
The MSRP today is $119.
Whoa!
Wow!
$119?!
There's a lot of ‐‐
It has
a computer inside.
Are you kidding?!
There's a lot of technology
inside of here.
It's reconfigurable.
What's the LICKI Brush
sell for?
Pre‐order is $19,
MSRP is gonna be $25.
That's more like it.
That's cool.
O'Leary: Guys, can
you just give me, for this year,
combined,
what total sales will be
in your forecast between
the licker and the egg?
Uh, our projected sales
for this year are $180,000.
So, what would
make you think
that you could price
this business
at over $2 million
in valuation?
We're really focused on
future revenues, so it's ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
So, we can give you the money
five years from now
in the future.
You can, but I'm gonna be
looking for a lot more
because I know
we're gonna double our revenue
next year and the year after
and the year after.
I've never heard anybody say
"I promise we're gonna fail."
This is so crazy.
I mean, it's just ‐‐
Well you guys know
as soon as this episode airs,
we're gonna ‐‐
This episode's gonna go viral.
I want to explain to you
something really important.
Everybody says,
"I want to go viral.
I'm gonna go viral."
Mm‐hmm.
We did. We did.
You said you went viral.
We had, like,
20 million views.
But your sales from that was
$250,000 on the one
and $52,000 on the other.
For going viral,
I think it should be higher.
I'm out.
Thank you, Lori,
I appreciate that.
I‐I have to tell you ‐‐
sales aren't there.
I'm sorry, I'm out.
Thank you, Robert.
Listen, I wish you wouldn't have
asked for so much so soon.
I mean, you only really have
a little proof of concept.
I don't know how
I get around that number.
Everybody has
the same problem ‐‐
You asked for too much.
I'm just thinking.
I go back to my office,
meet my team,
say I gave you 300 grand,
and I stick this in my mouth,
and they look at me and say,
"I'm getting a job
somewhere else now."
[ Laughter ]
Well, that's just
one product, though.
It's impossible to get back
the 300K.
Cuban: Guys, I'm simplify.
Look, you've had fun with it.
Obviously, you've owned it,
so it's become more than
just a business, right?
It's part of your personality,
looking for a big break.
You didn't price us
asking for a big break.
If you guys had come in
and said, "You know what,
believe in us,
50 grand for 20% of the company,
we all grow together."
Yeah, I think
we'd all be there.
Then somebody
could take a flyer.
Yeah. Yeah.
But 300K, that's too much,
and for those reasons, I'm out.
Thank you, Mark.
John: You know, it just reminds
me of an old story.
A cop ‐‐
an old‐school Irish cop ‐‐
He's walking down the block,
a woman runs up to him,
"Oh, my God.
My cat's in the tree."
He looks up in the tree,
and he says,
"Lady, you see any cat skeletons
hanging around up in this tree?
Sooner or later,
the cat's gonna come down.
They'll have to work it out."
We can't help you
with that valuation.
You're gonna have to work it out
by yourself.
I'm out.
Thank you, Daymond.
So, Mr. Wonderful,
we haven't heard from you.
I tell you ‐‐
I'm worried about my daughter.
My son would look at me and say,
"What happened to you, Dad?
Why did you do that?"
Well, we made you
a lot of money.
You're not worth 300K now.
It's just
too much money for this.
I'm out.
Guys,
I just want to say
how happy I am
that you met each other.
Thank you, Kevin,
so much.
We wish you good luck.
Of course,
we're disappointed.
Everyone wants
to get a deal,
but we also ‐‐
We have backup plans.
We have pending P. O. s.
We are going to build
this company,
and so this isn't
the end for us.
That was crazy!
Why do I do "Shark Tank"?
Because you never know
when someone's gonna lick a cat.
[ Laughing ]
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the tank
is a business designed
to make shopping
for men's basics easier
and more affordable.
Hey, sharks.
My name is Laura Dweck.
And I'm Michael Dweck.
We're from New York City,
and the founders
of Basic/Outfitters.
We're seeking an investment
of $125,000
in exchange for 10%
of our company.
Did you know
that on average,
men keep their underwear
for seven years?
[ Greiner laughs ]
What?!
Let that "stink" in
for a second.
Seven years.
Embarrassingly enough, I was
a victim of this statistic.
Really? I was the victim
in that statistic.
When we first got married,
I would not put up with it.
Michael's socks, underwear,
and undershirts
were faded and holier
than the Pope on Easter Sunday.
So, I did
what needed to be done.
[ Laughter ]
I just wanted
a quick and easy way
to refill everything I had
in my drawers
without having
to burn a paycheck.
I couldn't find anything
to satisfy those needs,
so we created
the solution.
Basic/Outfitters is
an online destination for men
to refill their drawers
with high‐quality basics
at affordable
price points.
You could choose
up to 10 pairs of socks,
three pairs of underwear,
three undershirts,
and a pair
of jogger sweat pants
all for $60.
That's the part where
people's jaws drop to the floor.
Yes, we just said $60
for up to 17 basics.
It's fast,
it's customizable,
it's high‐quality,
and it's affordable.
So, sharks, who's ready to
put an end to that nasty stink?
We have some amazing drawers
to hand out to you guys.
All right, Mr. Wonderful.
Robert.
John: Thank you.
Ooh, thank you.
And we have some Mavs colors
in there for you.
‐Appreciate it.
‐Thank you.
‐Feel those socks.
That's our basic drawer.
I'm a little blown away ‐‐
17 items for $60?
Did I hear that?
Yes, up to 17 items, yes.
Do I have to buy
an annual subscription?
No, this is not
a subscription model.
Greiner:
So, you pick and choose online.
You go online, and then you see
what pack fits you.
Correct.
I do have to say this is
the softest, most amazing sock
I have ever felt
in my entire life.
This stuff is amazing.
Thank you.
This stuff is
really good quality.
Thank you.
I mean, it's so ‐‐
It feels like cashmere!
Laura: Thank you.
How can you afford to sell it
at that price?
When we first started this,
we did some market research
to figure out what was
that sweet spot price
that would
wow customers.
We landed on $60.
So, we were relentless
in finding that price point
and working with
an amazing buying agency.
They found us
the factories.
So, I'm
one of those guys ‐‐
The last time
I bought underwear
was when Elvis did that comeback
concert in Hawaii, right?
[ Laughter ]
So, I get it.
But, I'm in stores all the time
that have underwear.
So, if I'm
not purchasing it then,
why am I home
thinking about going online,
putting in my credit card,
finding where you are,
and waiting for it?
Good question.
So, the real idea
came from
when Laura and I
first got married.
She challenged me
to throw out
anything that I hadn't worn
in about three months.
I just wanted
a quick and easy way
that I can refill, and when
I went to the department stores,
socks were in one place,
underwear was in another.
The pricing was
all over the place.
They had the audacity
of charging me $28
for one pair
of underwear.
How am I
supposed to refill?
I am wearing right now
a pair of underwear
from Switzerland that cost $99,
hand‐stitched
by Italian virgins.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, we learned that your price
selling point was great.
Yes.
But you never told us
your cost.
You're selling them for $60.
What's your cost on that?
It costs us, on average,
$25.90 to make a drawer.
What will
this year's sales be?
We're estimating
about $500,000.
So, what have you done
year to date,
and what have you done
the last twelve months?
You take that.
So, since we launched ‐‐
I like the way she decides
what you're gonna say.
[ Laughter ]
I'm married, I know.
I'm not even
supposed to ask.
‐You already know.
‐That's the way it should be.
‐And tell us when you will.
Laura and I launched the company
10 months ago.
Okay.
Since then, we've done
$351,000 in sales.
Wow!
How much inventory
in dollar amounts do you think
you'll end with
for this year projection?
So, right now, we still have
$397,000 in inventory.
Oh, so you went big
for your buy.
We went big.
Oh, wow!
Laura and I
invested $250,000
of our own life savings
into this.
Wow.
And how much
did you raise?
And we raised $750,000
in capital.
Wow, from who?
Feeling good.
We had outside investors
who really loved the idea,
and we were able to get
a million dollar valuation
on just concept alone.
And how much equity
do you have?
And where did
all that cash go?
We have 25% equity.
‐You have 25% equity.
‐Oh.
‐Sorry. Sorry. Sorry.
You gave away
75% of it already.
We did, because ‐‐
[ Groans ]
Sorry, Laura,
you sold 75% of your business?
Narrator:
All sharks are still in.
They're impressed
with the price and quality
of Laura and Michael's
men's undergarment business,
Basic/Outfitters.
But the sharks are
surprised to learn
they already sold the majority
of their business
in order to get it started.
You sold 75% of your business
before you started?
Laura:
Let me explain.
When we started this,
there was huge potential
based on the market research
that we did.
So, we knew that there was this
pocket of opportunity
we knew that we could
capitalize on.
So, we wanted
to build something big.
Wow. That's tough.
Guys, look ‐‐
market research is never right,
as you found out.
It's actually spot‐on with what
our hypothesis was. We know ‐‐
Then why would you spend
so much on inventory
and why would you give away
so much of your company
if you knew it was gonna
be right,
when all you'd have to do
is take your time to get there?
We wanted
to build the company.
We wanted to be
sitting on the inventory.
We also looked at ‐‐
You wanted to be sitting on
all that inventory?
We wanted
to be prepared.
Oh.
We wanted to be prepared.
We also knew ‐‐
We own ‐‐
We made that mistake.
I feel you've been screwed
by the V. C. s, you know that?
Wedgied.
Well...
No, it's not that
you've been screwed.
You screwed yourself.
The vision's good.
The product's good.
The execution is
ridiculous.
Worst I've ever seen.
We're looking
for the long haul.
We're here because
we're building this thing
to be an empire.
We're not looking to sell it
at $10 million.
Yeah, I ‐‐
We're looking
to go really big.
Yeah, but it's too late!
You blew it!
Capital management‐wise,
you're the worst I've ever seen,
so I'm out.
And I'm not mad at you,
I feel bad for you,
that there's
this great opportunity
that you created,
and it went "Pshew!"
Well, I'm mad at you.
And that's why we're ‐‐
That's why we're here today.
We want to make you
a lot of money.
You can't!
Herjavec:
No, but you can't!
We can!
Michael: You can't!
Guys, this is
a basic business.
Why can't we?
You know what, look.
Michael...
This is a basics business ‐‐
$76 billion.
... great business,
great idea.
But you cannot make a mistake
that's gonna kill you.
When you give away 75%,
you're dead.
You don't own this business
anymore.
I'm not talking
to the owner.
I'm talking
to the hired help.
It's crazy.
I'm out.
So, guys,
I love this stuff.
The quality is amazing.
I just knew I could put
my Bombas socks in there,
and they have online,
and it was gonna be great,
but you don't have enough equity
in the company.
You're gonna be miserable here,
and when you dropped that bomb
of you not having
that percentage...
it just hurt me,
actually, for you.
So, I'm out.
Guys, I look at this, uh,
this problem a different way.
It doesn't make sense
to take any of your equity
if I were to be an investor.
Here's an offer for you.
I would give you $125,000.
I want 25%, but I want the whole
25% to come out of them.
I wouldn't do the deal if
you told me he was deluding you,
because if you don't have 25%,
you don't have skin in the game.
But how can they
make that deal, Kevin?
We're here
on their behalf.
You know,
I'll tell you something ‐‐
When you came in ‐‐
Guys, that's
an offer, okay?
Thank you.
I appreciate the offer.
You know, I love
to copy Mr. Wonderful.
I will do $125,000
for the 25% that
you get out of your investors.
I'm doing it because I think
that the product is fantastic.
So basically,
you've made the same offer.
I crafted
the deal for you.
I would love to ask
if either of you
would want to come down to...
15% for $125,000.
Because we are
negotiating for them.
We value them
as investors,
and we value you guys
and we love the way
you're structuring,
and we appreciate
that you care.
O'Leary: I've just realized,
listening to you ‐‐
you actually
can't make this deal.
I'm dealing with a ghost
that's not in the room,
and that's the problem
with your structure.
You simply don't own enough.
I'm out.
Appreciate it.
Can you even negotiate?
What you want to do,
Lori?
You're talking about somebody
else's equity.
I know you were
countering back at 15%.
I will go 20%,
but that's it.
And you really have to
think about
whether or not they would
even consider this.
Wouldn't do it, Lori.
Let's make a deal.
‐20%?
‐But how can they do the deal?
‐But you have to check with your
investors first.
You have to check
with your investors.
You don't have the right
to make the deal!
We have the right.
We're here with their blessing.
So you think that your investors
are going to say,
"It's okay ‐‐ 20%. I will
give it away out of my cut."
100%.
You're positive?
We're not ‐‐
We're not positive.
I'm positive.
‐Really?
‐Oh.
‐Ah.
‐There you go.
O'Leary: They've said yes.
What do you want to do?
Well,
what does that mean?!
It's Lori's call.
Look, it's Lori's call.
I mean, Lori...
Lori, I think it would
close with a lot more certainty
if we could get this equity down
a little bit more.
‐Oh!
‐Oh, my ‐‐ Gaah!
‐Okay! Okay! Okay!
‐All right, I'm sorry.
Greiner: You know what?
We really ‐‐
This seems very tenuous.
We're ‐‐
We really ‐‐
I'm sorry.
I'm gonna have to go out.
We really want
to make a deal with you.
To make that deal,
you needed 51%.
Yep.
You're an employee,
both of you.
No, we're here
with their s‐‐
You're here,
but you're still employees.
Thank you so much.
Thanks, guys.
Thanks for listening.
We appreciate it.
Appreciate all your time.
Wow. You could feel
the air leave the tank...
Boom.
... as soon as they said
they sold 75%.
Yeah, I could see ‐‐ I was
hitting her with this stuff,
I could see her face
just start to drop.
That kind of made me sick.
Michael:
We don't think it's a mistake
that we gave up 75%
of our company.
We have 25% of a company
that's going to be huge.
And we're
really proud of that.
In season six,
Naushad Ali made a deal
with Robert Herjavec
for his clogged drain solution,
Drain Strain.
$110,000,
but I want 10%.
I'd love
to do a deal with you.
Done!
Narrator:
Let's see what he's doing now.
Hey, Naushad,
how are you?
Ali:
When I appeared on "Shark Tank,"
Drain Strain was just
a prototype.
We launched it retail
just three months ago,
and we're generating
tremendous sales and interest.
So, we got the Drain Strain
sink stopper.
I love the packaging.
In 2008, my family lost
everything including our home,
and we ended up moving
into a rental.
It was ironically
in that rental home
that our drains clogged
and was the eureka moment
for Drain Strain.
You've come a long way,
my friend.
Since "Shark Tank,"
we're now available
in 1,200 Home Depot stores,
and we have a purchase order
for 500 Lowe's stores.
When I was on "Shark Tank,"
we were pre‐revenue.
We've launched in retail
just three months ago
and generated $. 5 million
in sales.
And then
here's our bathtub prototype.
Herjavec:
What I've learned from Naushad
is this is the greatest country
in the world.
Everybody gets a second chance
if you're willing to work hard.
Naushad was at rock bottom,
and a few years later,
he's in 1,200 Home Depot stores?
Hallelujah.
Look at that.
Right at the end of an aisle.
This is just the beginning.
Today, Drain Strain ‐‐ tomorrow,
every drain in your house
with an entire
Drain Strain section.
I can see it.
The only thing left to do
is get more locations.
Well, let's do it.
Let's go work on that.
Ali: My family has endured
a lot of emotional
and financial challenges
over the last several years.
This has allowed me
to bounce back
and make my dreams come true
and leave a legacy
for my children.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next into the tank
is a patriotic take
on a favorite beverage.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Cade Courtley.
This is Ms. Betty Bean.
And I'm here asking for $250,000
for 20% equity.
Now, as a former Navy Seal,
a sniper,
and a security contractor,
I worked in some of
the most hostile places
on this planet.
Places like Bosnia, places like
Iraq and Afghanistan ‐‐
the kind of places
you're literally living
one hour at a time.
And things can go upside‐down
just like that.
Trust me when I tell you
when you're working
in an environment like that,
you crave just
a little sense of normalcy.
Now for me, that was
a damn good cup of coffee.
And that's why
I started Victory Coffees.
That, and it beats the hell out
of getting shot at.
[ Laughter ]
Now, Victory Coffees is
a veteran‐owned
and veteran‐operated company
whose only mission is
to deliver you amazing coffee.
Simply choose
one of our organically grown,
fairly traded,
premium international blends.
You can get it in whole bean.
You can get it ground.
And we are proud to announce
that we have
the world's strongest K‐Cups.
Thank you, Betty.
[ Laughter ]
And that's it!
So, folks,
life is too short,
so why not start your day
with a victory?
Now, Ms. Betty Bean
is going to deliver you each
two cups of coffee.
The one that you prefer,
if you wouldn't mind
slipping that mug forward,
please.
Herjavec:
I love coffee.
We have your initials
on the front of each mug.
Oh, thank you.
Betty Boop.
I like this one.
O'Leary:
You're taking a lot of risk with
this blind taste test thing.
Courtley: Yeah.
You know what?
He's a former sniper.
He over it.
He's used to risk.
I mean, you know.
There is coffee risk, and then
there's getting blown up risk.
So, the one in the white cups ‐‐
that's one of the country's
leading coffee sellers in that.
So, the folks that said,
"Hey, we like the gray one."
We have a better product
than one of
the biggest coffee companies
in the United States right now.
Okay, I chose the gray,
which is yours, darker.
Yes, sir.
Lori?
Greiner: I do think that yours
has a nicer flavor
for being a very heavy,
dark coffee.
Kevin,
what did you choose?
I chose the darker cup,
the gray cup, as you did.
'Cause you're a connoisseur
like I.
Of course.
Daymond?
I'll be very honest.
I tried them both,
and because I'm ‐‐ I mean,
I'm not a coffee drinker,
I can't tell the difference.
And Mark?
I like mine light.
I don't like real heavy, dark,
dark coffee at all.
Where's the coffee
come from?
So, we source from Central
and South America,
Africa, and Sumatra.
So, what made you choose
to go into something
that has such
a competitive field?
Well...
Was it Betty Bean?
[ Laughter ]
I would tell you ‐‐
I would tell you
that 83% of Americans
are drinking the stuff,
so I'm looking at
potentially
268 million customers,
and 56% of those folks admit
to being addicted to it.
Cuban:
Yeah. Okay, so, before...
Cade, Cade, Cade.
We're gonna save you some time.
I'm gonna save you
some time, right?
Yes, sir.
Rule number one
to "Shark Tank" is
when you talk about
market size...
Mm‐hmm.
... and start to suggest, "If I
only get a small percentage,
then I'm gonna make a killing,"
that's like ‐‐
‐That's scary for us.
‐Yeah, we hate that, Cade.
‐That's ‐‐ Yeah.
Yeah, that's a big red flag
because it does everything
but put the focus
on your business
and the execution
of your business.
Okay.
So, much more importantly is not
what's the size of the market,
because we know
people drink coffee.
What's the size
of your business?
Let me tell you
how Victory's different with ‐‐
Let's say you have two cups.
It's the exact same price,
exact same quality,
exact same convenience.
But why is your ‐‐
What's my differentiator?
Yeah.
Do not underestimate the power
of patriotism in this country.
But that gets you
in the door, right?
Yeah.
Thank you
for your service.
I don't want
to diminish that,
'cause there's
nothing more ‐‐
You were worth it.
Yeah, there's nothing
more important.
But on the busi‐‐
Now, back to
the business side of it.
Okay, you're
gonna get in the door.
Then what happens?
I just got
a major purchase order
from one of the biggest
insurance agencies
in this country.
So, what you're ‐‐
what you're telling us is
you're selling
on a direct commercial basis
to large companies.
That's the business‐to‐business
side of the house.
I initially began this company
as the business‐to‐consumer,
and it was basically
a subscription‐based
coffee company.
Online?
Yes, sir.
And how did you do?
What are your sales?
We have year‐to‐date sales
right now
of $30,000,
$0 advertising.
That's direct to consumer?
Yes, it is.
And that's over
what period of time?
That's over a period
of eight months.
Okay,
let's really drill down
into what you
actually have created,
because I'm going to
make the assumption ‐‐
because I'm familiar
with the whole sourcing
of coffee business ‐‐ You're not
really sourcing it yourself.
You're dealing
with a distributor.
I'm not, I went directly
to two of my Marine buddies
who set up shop
in Washington, D. C.,
and have been making coffee
for about three years.
O'Leary: So, you're only
buying beans from a ‐‐
They're roasters, Cade.
‐You yourself ‐‐
‐They actually ‐‐
‐No, no, he's going
through the roaster.
You're not buying
the coffee directly.
So, what you're really creating
is a marketing company.
You're right.
The coffee's
the same coffee
that you can get
from other people.
And you're absolutely right,
and that's why I was able
to get three major corporations
to decide,
"We're going to switch to this."
Cade, how
do you scale that?
Because most of the coffee
bought in corporations
is done
through third parties.
I'm glad you asked.
One of the things
I want to create
is what I call
the Victory Army.
And what I'm going to do is
I'm going to recruit,
train, equip, and deploy
an all‐veteran sales force.
And this is how
we're gonna scale.
And it's basically iconic
American businesses for ‐‐
You're trying to do
too much, Cade.
You're trying
to do too much.
Yeah, you're ‐‐
These are all ideas.
You haven't executed them yet.
I'm just trying to sell.
I know. I know.
You're a great
salesperson, right?
You've got the heart.
You've got the determination.
But what you don't have
is focus right now.
You can sell. You believe.
You've got the heart.
You know you're doing
the right thing.
That is an amazing skill
that not everybody has.
Just do that.
Mm‐hmm.
Everything else is
a complication. Just sell.
Okay.
I'm out.
You know, you picked coffee
because it's popular,
and you know that there's
a good market for it.
But the double‐edged sword is
is that at the same time,
there's a million people
out there making coffee
and selling coffee.
They own the market.
I always say
it's best to do something
that's a little bit different.
I'm out.
I appreciate what you say
about how competitive
and tough this is.
Sharks, I spent half of my life
making bad guys go away.
There's no way I'm gonna do
an attitude shift
from surviving
countless operations
in places like Afghanistan,
and give up
because somebody might not like
my light roast.
That's just not the way
I do business.
It is not even ‐‐ It is not even
a question of that.
It's not a question
of your character.
Uh‐huh.
Not at all.
It's not a question
of your character.
There is
no issue with you
making sure that you're gonna
get the job done.
But you're just
a little too early ‐‐
Maybe I can explain
a little bit more about ‐‐
You're gonna have to explain
to them. I'm out.
Thanks for your time.
O'Leary: Look ‐‐
Yes.
Everybody said
the same thing.
Nobody doubts you,
it's just way to early.
It's not investable
yet, Cade.
I'm out.
All right, thank you.
Cade, do you know
what the number 242 is?
And I love this.
I love this story.
I learned this
a long time ago.
No, I don't.
That's the amount
of venture‐capital firms
that Howard Schultz
went to
before he got funding
for Starbucks.
Who would've had the courage
to get up a 243rd time?
Nobody doubts
your character.
It's what you do with the
rejection today going forward.
I'm out today, but I wish you
all the best of luck.
Thank you very much.
Crush it, buddy.
Greiner:
Thanks for your service.
Herjavec: Thank you.
Thank you.
Bye, Betty Bean.
[ Laughs ]
Good luck.
Thanks, guys.
O'Leary:
That's a good brand.
Courtley: I will survive
in the coffee industry
the same way I survived
in Iraq and Afghanistan.
I will be better, quicker,
and smarter,
and I will crush
the competition.
♪♪
I'm Jason Sweeting.
And I'm his wife,
Angelica Sweeting.
And we're
from Miami, Florida.
We have two beautiful daughters
together.
They're actually the inspiration
behind our company.
It is so difficult
trying to raise two girls
in this day and age.
They are bombarded
with so many images of beauty.
Our company not only wishes
to set an example
for our little girls, but for
little girls all over the world.
You're so beautiful.
We have really made it
our mission to dispel the myth
that only certain types
of people are beautiful.
We want everyone to know
is that you're beautiful
just the way you are.
Good.
It's good?
We have put
all of our finances into this,
and while it may not have been
a lot of finances,
it was all
that we had.
And just seeing
little girls' lives
literally be changed is just
a fire under us to keep going.
We want to ensure
that little girls know
that they can do
and be anything.
1... 2... 3.
♪♪
Herjavec: Aww.
Greiner: I know.
Hi, my name's
Angelica Sweeting.
And I'm
Jason Sweeting.
These are
our two beautiful daughters,
Sophia and
Sydney Sweeting.
Our company is...
Together:
Naturally Perfect Dolls.
And we're here
seeking $200,000
in exchange for 20% equity
in our company.
Naturally Perfect Dolls aims
to change the standard of beauty
one doll at a time while
encouraging self‐acceptance,
diversity,
and letting girls know
that they can be
whatever they want to be.
I mean,
look at us, right?
We're all
a little bit different.
But our differences
shouldn't be ignored.
In fact, they should be accepted
and celebrated.
Right. Unfortunately,
the toy industry
isn't sending
the same message.
Multi‐culture children
are now the majority,
but less than 10% of dolls
represent them.
That's why we created...
Together:
Naturally Perfect Dolls.
Their features are true
to diverse women.
They have
darker skin tones,
wider nose shapes, fuller lips,
and curly hair.
You see,
Naturally Perfect Dolls
is dedicated to seeing
the full spectrum of beauty
displayed up and down
each and every toy aisle.
And in order to do this,
we need your help.
Let's make sure
that every little girl knows
that anything is possible,
because they are...
Together:
Naturally perfect.
We do have some samples
for you guys, some dolls.
You want
to check them out?
Absolutely.
This is Sophia?
This is Sophia.
Hi, Sophia.
That's Robert. You ‐‐
Watch your step.
Give him that book.
You have to give
this one to Lori,
and she's
also a queen, yeah.
Aww!
And she loves pizza.
Thank you.
I do.
That's, uh ‐‐
That's Kevin.
No, that's Mr. Wonderful.
Mr. Wonderful,
look at that.
Thank you.
Thank you, sweetheart.
He's really a teddy bear.
Don't worry.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know about that.
That's Mr. Daymond.
Thank you.
That's Mr. Mark.
There you go.
Bye, kids.
Look how happy she is.
Aww.
Herjavec:
She's like, "Phew!"
And like,
"No more Kevin, yeah!"
"We're done!"
"I do not want to be
in front of those sharks."
Thanks for coming!
Now you know, Angelica,
I am known ‐‐
My full name is Mr. Wonderful,
King of all Dolls.
Yes.
I like that.
Voodoo dolls.
In some circles I'm known as a
‐‐ as a doll‐ologist,
and some people call me the
Doll‐atollah. And here's the ‐‐
Doll‐atollah.
The Dolly‐lama.
Jason:
The King of Dolls says this ‐‐
As you know,
this attempt to multi‐cultural,
gender‐specific dolls
has been attempted
by the big doll guys,
the small doll guys.
Mm‐hmm.
It has.
All have been challenged.
What makes you think
you're gonna be successful?
We stared on
Kickstarter crowdfunding.
We had a goal
of $25,000.
We did that
within the first 48 hours.
We've more than tripled it
by the end.
How did you
come up with this idea?
Okay, so,
it's book fair day.
We're driving home,
and when we're driving,
my daughter starts crying.
She can't stop.
So, finally,
when she calms down, we say,
"Hey babe, like,
what's wrong with you?
You know,
what's wrong?"
She says, "Dad,
I'll never be beautiful.
I need yellow hair
and white skin,
so that way
I can be beautiful."
And we were, like,
totally devastated, you know?
You're right.
We were devastated.
And for us, we were thinking, as
parents, what did we do wrong?
And she just kept looking
at all the dolls and characters
that she constantly sees on TV
and in the stores,
and Jason and I really searched
high and low for a doll
that would be a positive
affirmation for our daughter,
and we found nothing.
I mean,
we went to every store.
So, from there, of course,
we thought,
"Well, let's just create
a doll on our own."
So, we created
the Angelica doll
with just an initial investment
of $1,500.
So, after we saw the change
in my daughter
in just a couple weeks
with affirmations in the doll,
we really thought,
"Could this help other people?"
We launched Angelica
May 2015,
sold out our inventory
in December,
and then we launched
four other dolls.
What did you sell it for?
We're retailing them
at $85 right now.
‐Oh, that's ‐‐
‐That's high‐end.
‐And what did it cost you?
‐That's pretty expensive.
‐Yeah.
‐That seems like a lot
for a doll.
Right. So, we did
a very small production run,
only 1,000 units, so right now,
our cost of goods sold
is $35,
which is very high.
And that's one reason why we're
here today for an investment,
because with an investment,
we can get that cost down.
Did you get orders
from retailers?
So, we had ‐‐
Of course, we had interest
from large retailers.
But they want our retail price
to come down to $35, $40.
That's what they want.
Max.
Exactly.
And that's below
your cost today.
Exactly.
For you to get down
to that price point,
you got to change
everything.
Right.
Well, we've done a bit of
the legwork on that right now.
We're in contact
with a new manufacturer
that's already
seen the doll,
already did a price point
for it.
What's their capacity?
$10.30, so
our new profit margin would be
somewhere
around 81, 82%.
It's not this ‐‐
It's not this form doll, right?
It's the same exact doll.
The same exact doll
So, are they manufacturing
for the big guys too?
Yes.
Right.
Greiner: Well, you guys are
impressive to me.
Recently though, just within
the last handful of months,
you might have seen it ‐‐
Mattel...
Yes.
Right.
...came out
with a whole campaign
of diversity
in their dolls.
Right.
So, you have
a long road ahead
because you have
a lot of competition.
For me, it's not the
right investment at this time.
I'm out.
But I love the message,
and the doll is really
a great, great quality doll.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Hey, guys,
tell me how the business looks
in your eyes
in three years.
Will you be purely online?
Will you be retail?
Well, I ‐‐ Well, Jason and I
personally both love
going direct
to consumer online.
Yes.
And we keep
our profit margins.
But for me,
it's really close to us,
and it's really, I guess,
personal to us
that little girls
can walk down a toy aisle
and see themselves.
So, I think eventually, when we
can handle mass production
and going into retail,
we do want to go that route.
Angelica, I think
that there's the problem.
And I understand
that might make you feel good...
Right.
... and maybe affirmative, but
I think there's the challenge.
Mm‐hmm.
You know,
the big companies,
they can create in mass volumes
that you can't get to.
And that's not being negative.
Right.
No, it's the truth.
It's just the reality
of where you are.
Right.
You know, you got to be honest
with yourself...
Mm‐hmm.
... where your
starting point is.
Right.
Mm‐hmm.
So, from
that starting point, to say,
"We're gonna go into retail.
We're gonna get to mass volume.
We're gonna get to
that price point."
Wow,
that's an uphill battle.
Right.
I admire you guys,
but I just can't see it.
That's
really unfortunate.
I can't see that path.
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you.
But thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
You know, the good news is
people have been concerned about
the doll being replaced
by technology for 20 years now.
Mattel still does over 2 billion
a year of the Barbie brand.
It's huge.
Yeah.
Yes.
I know all this 'cause I was one
of their largest shareholders
for a long time.
And it was challenging to see
others try and pursue niches.
I think there is a place for you
direct to your customer.
A $10 million business
would make your family
$1.5 million a year.
But I've lived
this life already,
and I didn't love it
in the end.
I'm out.
All right, thank you.
Sorry to hear that.
Thank you.
Cuban:
Guys, let me jump in.
Okay.
You guys are still
about the dream
in a lot of respects,
right?
Mm‐hmm.
My suggestion to you is
get on project green.
You know, the whole thing
about the vision,
when you walk down the aisles
you want to see your dolls.
Right.
That complicates things
in a big way.
You've got something
that's very unique to you...
Mm‐hmm.
... and that's working
for you.
Right.
Leverage that.
Follow the green.
Right now, you're a little bit
too scattered for me.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
But congratulations. You've done
an amazing job getting here.
Thank you very much.
I'd just like to speak
to your focus factor.
I'm a man with a family.
It's pretty much project green
every day.
[ Laughter ]
No, I hear that. Yeah.
You're right.
O'Leary:
Okay, you have one shark left.
Herjavec:
Daymond, what's your thought?
Narrator:
Four sharks are out.
Daymond is
Jason and Angelica's last chance
for a deal for their
multi‐cultural doll company,
Naturally Perfect Dolls.
I'm wrestling with the idea.
I really am.
Angelica:
Well, Daymond, let me say this.
We really tried
to replicate features
that are true
to women of color.
Our original Angelica doll
actually was sculpted
from my face
and my daughter's face, as well.
They're also very unique
because of our messaging.
People really relate to us,
our story, and our why.
I understand that.
I‐I‐‐
That's why I'm wrestling
with it,
because I think
I resonate with this, of course.
I‐I have three daughters.
I have a newborn now.
And my daughters are ‐‐
They're mixed.
So, I want them
to feel beautiful.
But the biggest challenge
I have
is probably
what everybody else had here.
Why retail?
Well, let me clarify.
I started off saying
that we love
the direct
to consumer model.
And we definitely want
to stick to that.
But I said as we grow, and maybe
we're a $20 million company,
and we can afford
to go in retail,
then maybe
that's the avenue.
I believe that it's about
business health.
We might have all these
fantastic goals,
but what's doable is
what's doable.
I have a family.
I mean, we might have
the biggest dreams in the world,
but while we keep
this dream on par,
we know ‐‐
we have to build a business,
and we have to be
sensible about it.
If you're willing
to bend like that,
then I'll give you
an offer.
I'll give you $200,000
for 33 1/3%
so all three of us
are equal partners.
Wow.
33%, 33%, 33%.
I, uh ‐‐
Would you ‐‐
Would you consider
maybe backing that down
to maybe 25%?
[ O'Leary and Greiner laugh ]
Don't you want me to be
a partner, full partner?
I love you, and I do want you
to be a partner.
In fact, I'm feeling
very partnerly right now.
[ Laughter ]
I love you, man.
I feel the love.
I love you.
I do want you to be a partner.
I feel the love.
But...?
But you know, I mean,
I love 33 and 33.
‐And 33.
‐You do.
You're right there.
Okay.
What do you think?
Well, baby,
you always choose
what we gonna do,
sweetheart,
so what you want ‐‐
So, Daymond, is there any wiggle
room on your equity offer?
What's ‐‐ What's the reasoning
for the wiggle room?
Um, Jason and I
honestly believe
that we can grow this company
to $100 million company.
We've had calls
from Dove.
We have ‐‐ have calls
from major hair‐care companies
just wanting to put
their product in our doll boxes,
so that little girls
around the world will grow up
with their
hair‐care products.
We're selling more
than just dolls.
We're selling
tools of confidence,
tools of
self‐affirmation.
There's something really
powerful about our message.
One of the most important things
about our Kickstarter
is it wasn't just
an African‐American thing.
We had Asian moms, Indian
moms ‐‐ everyone contacting us.
Yes, even dads saying,
"Hey, we want a doll
that looks like
our culture,
somebody that represents
our daughters."
Let's do this wiggle room.
Okay.
I'll take 30%...
you guys will take 60%,
and 10% goes towards
some kind of charity
of women empowerment
and girls empowerment
so we all go down a little,
but everybody else gets money.
That a deal?
I think that's great.
So ‐‐ So ‐‐
[ Applause ]
Good job.
[ All talking indistinctly ]
Thank you, boss.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
You're the boss.
And thank you guys.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, guys.
You're really smart
for listening to us.
Hey, I got to
do my best, man.
You understand that,
right?
Yes. Yes.
Okay.
Thank you.
Thank you, my man.
[ Both laughing ]
Hey. You're, all right, man.
You did it!
Good job! You did it!
I love that we're ‐‐
We have a portion of our deal
going to charity.
Yeah, that's awesome.
That's the best place
for it to go.